this leaflet tells you what the new
National Health Service is read it
carefully in 70 years the NHS has
revolutionized the health of British
people we could now be on the threshold
of the biggest revolution of all when
the roadblock cuts the robot cuts in the
right place technology will soon change
medicine as we know it I can look on the
screen and then they prescribed it from
wherever they are in seconds in 70 years
time diseases that have blighted the
lives of millions of people who may be
on the verge of defeat that level of
manipulation is happening but will what
is good for us also be good for the NHS
we have to be cautious and careful and
make our own decisions not just take
what the marketplace wants to salicin
[Music]
the surgical robots are bringing science
fiction to life but they come with an
intergalactic price this is Mako a
critical member of this surgical team at
the Princess Grace Hospital in
the robot now a very key part of your
team today Makos carrying out a hip
replacement on Richard Ellis who is 57 I
still walk the dogs but rather slowly
and I generally have a stick now the
benefits of robotic surgery is its
precision
reducing pain for the patient with a
shorter recovery time they will try and
get me up by the end of the day which is
extraordinary actually isn't it one
under seven operation it made perfect
sense to me with recovery times and and
and pain that all seem to add up
rather well so yeah I think it was it
was definitely part of the
decision-making process
we followed Richard into surgery and saw
make her at work this the robots 200th
operation he also does knee replacements
alongside his boss professor Haddad a
pioneer of robotics in the UK so huge
differences to me as a surgeon in that
we've got much more detailed planning
preoperatively we get a CT scan which
allows us actively to create a model and
do a virtual operation before we start
and then we have this wonderful feedback
from the computer and the robot during
surgery that allows us to adjust that
plan very very accurately when the robot
cuts the robot cuts in the right place
do you think the future for surgeons
will be a console pad and not in scrubs
like you are today I think that my type
of surgery the future will still be
scrubbed and operating but we'll be
operating with assistance and I think
that's the beauty of this I think
there's no question that this is if you
there is no industry where the robotics
have come in where they've left again
it's the way forward well this may be
the future the NHS so far only owns one
of these robots it's expensive kit and
not an easy transition so you mix
traditional methods with another massive
breakthrough for the NHS is replacing
paper with data these computers may not
look like much but they're almost as
powerful as a team of medics they're
already relieving much of a nurse's work
recording patients conditions and using
the data to issue doctors rulings
there's an awful lot in here that is
automated now that makes their life
quicker and easier and that frees that
time up to go and care we're in critical
care at the Queen Elizabeth Hospital in
Birmingham virtually a paperless unit
now can you believe these enormous
charts are still used in most hospitals
one per day per patient you can imagine
if a patient stays in critical care for
three weeks there are folders of these
this would normally be scribbled all
over and very unclear as to what the
patient had received whereas you can see
yourself that this is very clear every
time your checked at your bedside the
information is stored and shared the
system will take that information and
will compare it to what would be a well
patient when the patient as observations
deteriorate you want various people to
know that the patient's ill it will also
fire the system to send out alerts and
emails to various staff around the
hospital and so without checking any
records they can know that the patient
system alerts the addicts that someone
is in a bad way yes out of critical care
and onto a ward digitizing records means
patients are getting their care
faster okay oh sure I'm just gonna scan
your respond if that's okay
lovely I sure has been in and out of
hospital all her life with kidney
failure now by having a digital profile
doctors can treat her almost instantly
everything just happens really quickly
if I need pain relief and this is only
would take five minutes to give it to me
what does it tell you when you scan the
wristband as soon as you scan the
wristband it allows you to sort of enter
the rest of the program and then you can
continue giving the medication because
that's a correct patient and you can see
all of this patients profile you can
indeed everything comes up on the system
and can you imagine living without
Vanessa yeah never I think it's just
brilliant it just really saves so much
time he'll eventually with the NHS now
how busy isn't how short-staffed you are
and having all of this together just
makes your job so much easier
oh I actually have never known anything
different unless are working into the
hospital then you really see that you
really see the difference and how much
tougher is that with paper Oh like it's
just to be honest when doctors want to
prescribe something they have to take
the chill chat away from the patient's
notes so if you wonder what's that if
you want to go and administer some
medication and you have to go and find
the drug chart whereas here I couldn't
ring the doctor and say the patients in
pain can you please please prescribe
somehow easier and then straight away I
can look on the screen and then they
prescribed it from wherever they are in
seconds in seconds if I got that five
six years ago I'd have to be waiting
hours on end for pain relief and it
wasn't the staffs fault it was just the
way the system was and now we'll have to
do is ask then I've got my pain
but this is just the beginning of the
sort of technology you may soon find on
your hospital ward fast forward to the
future and your hospital ward could look
something more like this
with a nurse able to adjust the
conditions at the touch of a button
allowing you to sleep better because
light has been directly linked to a
patient's recovery they can boost the
amounts you get and monitoring your
condition could become far less invasive
as well by simply wearing one of these
biosensors medics will get all the
information they need wherever they are
we're at the Philips Research Laboratory
in the Netherlands this is where they
invent the high-tech hospital equipment
of tomorrow like this using augmented
reality to change spinal surgery forever
we've added cameras to the system so you
are able to see on the outside of the
patient the inside of the patient the
alternative would be open surgery so you
could actually see what you're doing now
we're providing visual feedback to the
surgeons so we can actually perform at
the minimally invasive mammal evasive
means less of a wound quicker recovery
times soon on the patient gets home
this hybrid operating theater means
diagnosis and treatment can happen
almost simultaneously a team of surgeons
radiologists and other specialists can
carry out x-rays and operations in the
same room at the same time
this sort of technology opens the door
to untold possibilities for the future
of healthcare these are some of the most
advanced bits of kit for treatment and
diagnosis everything like this
ultrasound is getting smaller more
powerful and more precise and while this
may look like a glimpse into the future
the reality is much of this is already
on its way to the NHS the notion that
all of the kits that you need to be
diagnosed sits in a hospital changes
ultrasound machines which are large
trolly based bits of kit that are
wheeled around hospital then our
handheld devices that could be plugged
into an ordinary tablet and they can
produce 80 to 90% of the same kind of
diagnostic tests today that that large
kit can do so imagine what it will look
like in 70 years time so the notion that
the hospital I think comes to you in the
community in your home I think is a
fundamental part of how the healthcare
system will look in 17 years from today
digitizing the NHS is store of tens of
millions of medical records is another
huge opportunity it has a fairly
disastrous record in data privacy and IT
contracts but if it can get it right the
NHS could find itself in a unique
position I think the UK is better place
than frankly any nation on earth to put
these kind of systems and hospitals
helping a doctor make sense of an
incredibly complex range of data sources
you know blood tests urine tests and
soon data on genetics and you know gene
regulation it is just an incredible
amount of data and so I think that the
way I would I would try to convince a
skeptical member of the public here
would be to point out how difficult a
job a doctor has in trying to grapple
with that complex situation and making
the point that the Machine really could
help them out a lot data sharing offers
huge possibilities for diagnosis
but what if doctors could preempt your
illness by reading your DNA congenic a--
is one company already working on the
first stages of this process with the
NHS that st. George's Hospital in London
decoding a patient's genes to predict
the best treatment for them when I first
affected my career maybe about 25 years
ago we could look at very small portions
of genes and it was very expensive
until could a whole gene was would take
years literally years so patients would
wait years for a diagnosis now we can do
a whole human genome in the NHS it can
be done and the results can be returned
to patients with Emily but the next step
is editing your DNA to eradicate
diseases altogether and this is
something that could happen before
you're even born we've seen so much
change you think about mitochondrial
disorders where a woman who carries a
mitochondrial condition even though she
herself might be well but her offspring
are a significant risk of potentially
really being affected by the condition
we have these new techniques which are
just starting where you transfer the
nucleus from her egg making sure you
don't take any mitochondria from her egg
into another woman's egg where there are
totally normal
mitochondria and remove and remove the
nucleus that's in that egg and then you
know she's able to have a child with
great reassurance that the child won't
have one of these devastating
mitochondrial diseases that level of
manipulation is happening so yes it did
it is on the horizon I think but with
that comes many ethical questions that
it could lead to social cleansing and a
race of superhumans available only to
those that could afford it I think
there'll always be a minority who want
to throw money of this loads of people
are dominated by very superficial ideas
of what people should look like and what
their capacities should be Tom
Shakespeare who was born with
achondroplasia says it's a dangerous
idea the number of people with
disabilities who've built the world we
live in is extraordinary you and I and
everybody else uses the internet and our
smartphones all the time who designed
that mostly people on the autistic
spectrum
Silicon Valley full of people on the
autistic spectrum this is where in a
heart of cultural London who drives the
culture that we love gay people you know
these are the diversity and differences
which make our lives better so we don't
need to start trying to make us all
homogenous white heterosexual
able-bodied six-foot tall boring dull
unimaginative people history shows
developments in technology have the
biggest impact in transforming care 70
years from now the possibilities are
almost limitless more effective more
personalized treatments whether for
cancer or chronic kidney disease
there are many incredible breakthroughs
within our grasp but it's private
companies that now hold the reins to
innovation the notion that you go to a
large place and a district General
Hospital or a or a GP clinic to receive
your care I think will change financing
healthcare will always be the greatest
challenge the vision for the future is
packed with possibility it's not like on
screen it will be in your glasses right
so so if we still use augmented reality
it will be what you see is you see
inside the patients but in solving new
problems and answering tough ethical
questions we'll need the same creativity
[Music]